on
l'aéroport international
montréal-trudeau reprend lentement vie
mais ces activités sont encore au
ralenti ce qui n'a pas ralenti au cours
de la dernière année toutefois ce sont
les saisies réalisées aux douanes au
canada entre avril 2020 et avril 2021
le nombre de saisies toute marchandise
confondues est passé de 51 mille à 75000
une hausse de 50 % les quantités de
fantanele autres hôpitaux et des saisies
ont augmenté tout comme celle des
produits illégaux du cannabis et d'armes
prohibées enfin c'est pas parce que le
nombre de voyageurs a diminué que nous
on a arrêté de travailler et criminels
et les contrebandiers
c'est pas une pandémie qui va les
arrêter 1 il ya un marché à faire rouler
donc fallu continuer si le nombre de
voyageurs qui arrivent au canada a chuté
de plus de 90% dans cette année de
pandémie les agents des services
frontaliers ne se sont pas tournés les
pouces pour autant presque chaque jour
l'équipe de marie-eve letellier effectué
des saisies
on a trouvé des métamphétamines et on a
trouvé des quantités de cocaïne on a
trouvé des quantités d'héroïne ça
continue toujours on parle de drogue de
devises de
d'objets de luxe c'est la nature humaine
donc pandémie pour pandémie des gens qui
veulent essayer de de se faufiler n'a
système il va toujours en avoir maxime
sauriol et son compagnon de travail
guzzo spécialiste de la détection de
produits alimentaires et agricoles ont
remarqué un phénomène nouveau ces
derniers mois étonnamment on avait on a
vu beaucoup de passagers qui a apporté
de la nourriture pour la quarantaine
donc pour faire les allemands à la
maison c'est un effet c'est quelque
chose qu'on voyait pas avant évidemment
donc des passagers qui veulent être
préparés pour faire la quarantaine parce
que les gens portaient des aliments sans
nécessairement savoir si c'est
admissible ou non donc gonzo été bien
occupé avec mes skis explique surtout la
hausse des saisies c'est ce qui se passe
à l'extérieur de la zone des voyageurs
avec la fin des mises qu'on a constaté
c'est que les contrebandiers trouver des
façons plus des façons différentes
ils ont des portées le produit au canada
donc on a vu une explosion si on peut
ainsi dire de haut niveau de la
messagerie le commerce en ligne lui de
plus en plus de colis qui ont été reçus
dans nos installations et les
contrebandiers en ont profité pour
glisser de plus en plus de leurs
marchandises à l'intérieur de ces mêmes
colis parmi les c6 notoire 25 kg d'opium
ici 1500 kg de masques n95 frauduleux
oui avec ondes radio nouveau cargo mais
si une chose qu'on a fait de bien
pendant la pandémie par exemple au
niveau de l' agence faut quand même le
souligner qu'à partir du mois de
décembre on a quand même accueilli 25
millions de doses de vaccin parce que la
pandémie vous avoir amené en fait c'est
des nouvelles techniques de travail des
nouveaux outils de travail aussi dont
l'application arrêts cam arrive quand on
a vu le jour pendant la pandémie pour
accompagner les voyageurs avant leur
arrivée au canada et pendant leur
quarantaine c'est sûrement appelé à
rester pour une période prolongée donc
nous ici ce qu'on fait très bien c'est
qu'on s'adapte on va continuer à le
faire ça c'est certain
donc quand les restrictions vont être
levés nous on va être prêt pour être là
pour accueillir tout le monde
et les douaniers ont bien raison de se
préparer parce que dès juillet les
canadiens est résident permanent
pleinement vaccinés qui reviennent de
l'étranger pourront bénéficier d'
assouplissement promesse d'un afflux de
voyageurs renouvelé à nos frontières il
si fanny bussières mais nicole radio
canada montréal